as expected vladimir putin has launched
a full-scale russian invasion of ukraine
the invasion extended far beyond the
contested breakaway regions in the east
of the country going all the way to the
nation's capital of kiev where
explosions could be heard on television
in the middle of the night
ukrainians who who resist oh
i tell you what i just heard a big bang
right here behind me i thought we
shouldn't have done the live shot here
there are big explosions taking place
in kiev right now
um i can't see where they're taking
place from this vantage point here on
top of the roof of the hotel in central
kiev and
i can't explain what they are but i
heard four or five
explosions a few moments ago don't know
whether our viewers or whether you in
the studio there could hear
what we can do what i just heard
there is going to be lots of finger
pointing over the next few days there's
going to be a lot of damage control from
our own country's ruling elite
but you should make no mistake
this is joe biden's fault
everybody knew that putin wanted to
conquer ukraine along with many other
neighboring countries putin invaded
georgia under george w bush he invaded
crimea under obama he paused the
invasions under donald trump now he has
invaded ukraine under biden it is not
just biden's bad luck that putin chose
this moment to invade he is invading
ukraine right now because joe biden made
specific decisions that encouraged him
to do it
donald trump instituted sanctions on
russia
biden lifted those sanctions
trump shut down putin's nordstrom 2
pipeline which would give russia direct
access to the european oil market joe
biden gave the green light to the
pipeline removing all the leverage that
ukraine ever had
trump kept putin on his toes and in line
biden literally invited him to invade
ukraine just so long as the invasion
were only a minor incursion
i think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having to fight about
what to do and not do etc wow really
tough talk there's the leader of the
free world all right mr alligator you
can have my pinky but you'd better not
take the whole hand there it is don't
don't you better you can have okay you
can have two fingers but don't okay well
that's american leadership no wonder we
see what's happening now in ukraine it
is impossible to prove a counterfactual
but it seems safe to say that this would
not be happening right now if donald
trump were still president but elections
even dubious elections have consequences
the jello-headed cadaver currently
occupying the oval office has been in
power for just one year and already the
post-cold war world order is crumbling a
high price to pay but hey
at least no more mean tweets i'm glad
you like that clip i like that clip too
now
ring the bell subscribe you have to
subscribe you must
do it that way you will get
notifications also
probably the better way to do it head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael noel
show leave a five star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]